[Musik]
[Applaus]
denn
[Musik]
[Applaus]
seit dem letzten video ist es auf einmal
ganz schnell winter geworden
und es hat sich auch wieder viel getan
bei uns und deswegen möchte ich euch
gerne mitnehmen und zeigen es die
letzten wochen so alles passiert ist
[Musik]
gerade gesehen dass ich den knoblauch
noch gar nicht abhängt habe also das
meist schon zu hause aber den tut ist
bestimmt nicht gut hier die ganze zeit
auf umzubauen
[Musik]
mit der wintersonnenwende war über nacht
plötzlich alles und eiskristallen
überzogen eine unserer wichtigsten
aufgaben ist es dann dafür zu sorgen
dass die tiere trinkwasser haben
das immer wieder einfriert
[Musik]
das ist zwar viel arbeit aber dadurch
dass es in den letzten jahren oft viel
zu warm war im winter vor ich mich immer
wenn es mal so richtig knackig kalt ist
[Musik]
ich denke alleine zu hause und kennen
wir das dass ihr dann überhaupt keine
lust habt zu kochen kochen macht einfach
viel mehr spaß wenn jemand mit ist
nämlich ein geheimnis verraten ich liebe
es trotzdem bereit zu sein
[Musik]
die letzten monate war eine aufgabe
richtig gut bei uns im kurzen eck team
und zwar nehmen wir beiden wieder neue
kurs teilnehmen denn auf in unseren
gemüsegarten staaten onlinekurs das ist
mit abstand das größte projekt das wir
beim wurzelwerk haben und das bo milch
und auch das gesamte objekt ihm am
meisten antreibt fragen immer die leute
vorher nachher bilder machen und das ist
so ruhig zusehen wie diese
transformation über ein jahr stattfindet
das ist unglaublich letzten monate war
ich deswegen ganz wie ihr mit filmen
beschäftigt und mit überarbeiten wenn
wir den kurs jedes jahr irgendwie besser
machen und dieses jahr ist auch sehr
sehr sehr viel besser geworden ich bin
schon richtig richtig stolz der schönste
tag als fast das gesamte team bei mir im
garten würde weil wir ein großes
filmprojekt hatten und zwar wollten wie
ein video dazu machen wie man die
komplette die wir offene pappe angelegt
haben wie man die auch ohne papa anlegen
kann weil viele leute die pappe nicht im
garten haben wollen da haben wir jetzt
eben noch ein paar projekte um zu zeigen
wie man die würfel genauso toll auch
ohne papa anlegen kann es hat mega viel
spaß gemacht und ich bin so dankbar dass
ich so unglaublich tolle leute in meinem
team habe
[Musik]
naja
der winter ist für mich die schönste
zeit um auf das zurückliegende
gartenjahr wir schauen uns überlegen was
gut gelaufen ist und was nicht gut
gelaufen ist was ich machen kann damit
die sachen die gut geklappt haben auch
wieder gut klappen und ich die sachen
die nicht gut gelaufen sind im nächsten
jahr besser hinkriegen natürlich bringt
das gar nichts nicht deswegen letzte weg
zu machen wie jedes jahr wachsen manche
kulturen besser und manche weniger gut
allein schon weil das wetter immer
unterschiedlich ist und das ist auch
völlig okay so
[Musik]
so lange haben wird machen wir wählen
viel zeit für einen frühjahrsputz im
garten hier sieht es nicht gut aus
überall flickzeug rum
und stehen noch ein paar freunde
pflanzen im beet die ich so lange hätte
abernten vor allen
[Musik]
b
ich habe hier so richtig schöne
vogelhäuschen oder vogelnester geschenkt
bekommen und die hängen wir jetzt mal
auf
[Musik]
doch diese entweder ich hab mich mal
wieder selten dämlich angestellt
das ist nicht so einfach dir diesen
komischen kleinen clips dann hier an
einem baum fest zu machen deswegen
musste eine andere halterung hier ich
will wirklich dass das klappt weil es
gibt nur noch so wenig vögel und die
haben so wenig lebensraums wenn so eine
kleinigkeit vielleicht schon hilft es
denn besser geht dann ist es total
wichtig dass jeder in seinem garten
macht
[Musik]
dass der ort
ich habe
[Musik]
wir gehen jetzt noch kekse zu backen
weil der ist nämlich morgen zum rigotti
fährt sogar die partie und den wollen
wir ein paar lustige riga die kekse
backen
er verbirgt sich natürlich der nils den
bestimmt ganz viele von euch auch von
seinem kanal seiten vielfalt kennen
was wird das gewollten
in der vene
darüber aufklären die musterung ist das
in der bühne war
[Musik]
ein bisschen
sieht man dort
[Musik]
[Applaus]
diese kataloge sim-karte angekommen ich
bin zu einem schlafanzug weil ich
manchmal sehr früh schlafen gehen damit
ich früh aufstehen kann weil ich das
irgendwie sehr gerne mag aber dadurch
dass der nähe ins gleiche noch mal
vorbeikommen wollte um der decke
abzuholen wenn ich dir jetzt auch noch
mal auspacken snell beste ausrede
[Musik]
will das so wenn die saatgut kataloge
kommen das ist so schön weil meine
mission shopping rausch ich wollte sie
auf jeden fall was erzählen ja ich habe
ich mir auch was für mehrzad gut
überlegt weil das irgendwie zu chaotisch
ist und ich habe mir zu boxen so foto
boxt gekauft weil ich fühle mich auch
glaube ich dann so richtig erwachsen
wenn ich es richtig organisiert habe
jahren auch so richtig erwachsen ich
finde vor allem also mit dem
reagenzgläser hat für mich auch wirklich
in so einen ästhetischen fakten hatte
dieser gesagt dass ich sie so diese
kiste dichter gebracht hat und weder
fahne
männer
adapter
die gäste
[Musik]
sie ist
aus
[Musik]
während einige den berg hinauf
örtliche macht
sommer
es kommt nämlich nicht
[Musik]
so